ja es gibt in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
ja wenige Dinge auf die man sich
wirklich verlassen kann aber in einem
lässt uns die Bundesregierung wirklich
nicht im Stich sie ist Tag und Nacht
damit beschäftigt neue teure Posten zu
schaffen und neue wuchtiges Logans zu
kreieren und diese Posten schafferei und
sloganproduktion gabelt sich nun auf
gipfelt sich nun auf in einem neuen
Slogan für das Auswärtige Amt man will
dort künftig und zwar ausschließlich und
immer und überall feministische
Außenpolitik betreiben so steht es in
einem Papier das nächste Woche
veröffentlicht werden soll einen Entwurf
ist bereits diese Woche den Medien
zugespielt worden oder muss sagen was
früher einmal die hohe alte Kunst der
Diplomatie war sondern ersetzt werden
durch so heißt es dort unter anderem
einen feministischen Reflex und durch
Diversität Kompetenz schon bei der
Einstellung zurück gefragt werden nicht
etwa ob man große Kenntnisse des 19 und
18 Jahrhunderts habe oder viele Sprachen
sprechen nein man sollte ausdrücklich
auch auf Diversität Kompetenz abgefragt
werden das heißt die Meteo können die
mittelmäßigen und die kulturkämpferinnen
werden sich dort versammeln man will ein
gender Budget Mainstreaming haben alle
Ausgaben sollen darauf geprüft werden ob
sie auch feministischen Zwecken dienlich
werden und man will auch im Ausland
auftreten wie die Axt im Walde und das
finde ich ganz besonders verwerflich
wenn man also als Gast ist das ganze
Team des Auswärtigen Amtes will man im
Ausland nur dann an öffentlichen Podien
teilnehmen wenn diese Geschlechter
paritätisch besetzt sind also viel Spaß
dann im Iran im Afghanistan in Tunesien
in Marokko oder auch ein Kambodscha wenn
man sagen wird wenn du dann Teilen auf
dem Podium gleich viele Männer wie
Frauen sind nein das ist der alte
Deutsche waren die Welt wieder einmal
nach der eigenen Ideologie zurecht zu
schustern ich finde das sehr sehr
bedauerlich auswärtige Politik sollte
die Kunst der Diplomatie sein das heißt
man setzt sich mit unterschiedlichen
Interessen an einen Tisch und redet
friedlich darüber stattdessen aber sind
die Deutschen und Weltreisende in
eigener Ideologie Hintergrund erteilen
sogar den Gastgebern noch Moral
Fleißkärtchen oder Versagen den üben da
kann ich leider nur sagen setzen sechs
wir brauchen eine gute eine kompetente
aber bitte keine keine rein
feministische Außenpolitik mal andersrum
gefragt Herr Kistler was macht denn
Annalena baerbock aus ihrer Sicht gut
gibt's da noch was was macht sie gut sie
ist fleißig ja sie ist fleißig sie ist
fleißig muss ich sagen sie findet
manchmal auch den richtigen Tonfall im
Ukraine Krieg auch den richtigen Tonfall
manchmal gegenüber dem Iran alles in
allem bleiben allerdings dann die Taten
hinter den Worten zurück und sie lässt
sich leider Einspannen von diesem
ideologischen
weltverbesserungswahn der Grünen die sie
da auf Ticket gebracht haben und jetzt
offenbar ihre Rechnungen präsentieren
und sagen du musst es wirklich die
Handelsreisende des Feminismus werden
und man will das wirklich so heißt es
dort in diesem Papier man wirklich eine
weltweit führende Rolle eine
Vorreiterrolle spielen oder kann ich nur
sagen was für eine Ignoranz die beiden
letzten Mal wird Deutschland
Vorreiterrolle waren wollte war als
Arbeiter Migrationspolitik hat nicht
geklappt danach bei der Energiewende
wird auch nicht klappen das heißt immer
wenn Deutschland vorreiten will sitzt
man allein auf dem Pferd schaut nach
hinten und niemand folgt und das ist
glaube ich das was ich so ganz stark
diese momentanen Bundesregierung
vorwerfen man will weltoffen sein
freundlich allen wohl keinem weh und de
facto will mal knallhart die eigene
Ideologie die außerhalb des eigenen
Landes auf wenig gegen Liebe stößt
durchsetzen also man ist gerade nicht
weltoffen man ist letzten Endes in einem
nationalen weltbeglückungswagen gefangen
ich habe nur eine Hoffnung das wird sich
totlaufen ich glaube die Weltbevölkerung
spielt damit nicht mit man wird dort zu
Hause schöne Instagram Fotos machen Frau
bärburg umgeben von Feministinnen und
solchen die ist noch gar nicht wissen
aber sich zu solchen identifizieren und
das würde dann auch gewesen sein ein
letztes noch ist auch ganz schlimmer
Taschenspieler Trick man merkt dann
Feminismus hat nicht so furchtbar tollen
Klang bei allen und sagt ja Feminismus
liegt auch dann vor wo wir die
Diskriminierung aufgrund des Alters
angehen also der Kampf gegen altersdiskr
Bildung ist es auch feministus wenn ich
eine Feministin wäre würde ich sagen
dafür bin ich 68 nicht auf die Straße
gegangen das 50 Jahre später gegen
altersdiskündigung gekämpft wird als der
Begriff wird auch da entholt entwertet
man hat Begriffe die man falsch anwendet
ein Ideologie die sich durchsetzen wird
man handelt gegen die eigenen Interessen
nur für die eigene Blase erinnern uns
zurück es ist schon ein bisschen her da
habe ich gefragt was finden sie
eigentlich noch gut an einer lederberg
ung auch was ganz kleines nämlich haben
sie ganz kurz finden Sie auch zumindest
in der Kriegsfrage da ist ja
Außenministerin straight da weiß man
ganz genau da haben sie vielleicht sogar
noch andere Punkte wo sie sagen okay da
muss ich wirklich sagen der macht ihre
Sachen gut
Outfit gut aber was sagen
oder nein aber nein eine Situation das
vollkommen ohne ironisch jetzt von mir
die fand ich wirklich stark als sie sich
nämlich für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine ausgesprochen
hat mit dem Hinweis auch dann wenn das
gegen den Strich der eigenen Partei der
eigenen Wähler gehen würde also selbst
für den Fall dass ihre eigenen Wähler
dagegen wären würde sie sich immer für
eine konsequente Unterstützung der
Ukraine einsetzen das hat mir imponiert
das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber ich
sehe das deshalb nicht ganz so
problematisch
Außenministerium der Film mit der
feministischen Außenpolitik weil es
Außenministerium schon seit langer Zeit
irrelevant ist also auch
eine unendliche Katastrophe ja sehr sehr
wichtig ja theoretisch schon aber ich
sehe das eigentlich seit Genscher und
sehe ich das eigentlich gar nicht mehr
so dass da die entscheidende Politik
gemacht wird das läuft dann relativ
schnell auf der Ebene des Kanzlers oder
der Präsidenten ab und es wäre natürlich
schön und hilfreich wenn wir politische
Fähigkeiten hätten aber wie Herr Kissler
ja vollkommen zurecht gesagt hat wir
haben ja Diplomatie komplett ersetzt
durch moralischen humanitarismus ja also
das ist auch diese Werte orientierte
Politik die natürlich vollkommen
unmöglich macht dass man noch
Realpolitik betreibt also das die
Politik ist genau in dem Moment modern
geworden und auch funktionsfähig
geworden für eine moderne Welt als sie
sich emanzipiert hat von der Moral und
genau das wird jetzt widerrufen also die
Moral wird also die wertet werden als
Maßstab für politisches Handeln und
politische Urteile angesetzt und im
Zweifelsfall entscheidet man sich für
die Werte und gegen die Realität das
Problem
als Frau sie finden doch vielleicht
etwas Positives an Annalena Berger muss
ja sagen in der Außenpolitik das ist
jetzt wirklich ja nicht das Steckenpferd
der Frauen da gibt's vielleicht auch
wirklich Punkte wo man sagen kann dann
müssen wir mehr Frauen reinholen finden
Sie die Entwicklung positiv haben sie
einen tollen Punkt und ich sehe es genau
wie sie das in der Außenpolitik ähm
gerade aus Deutschland natürlich Frauen
bisher da nicht so präsent waren ich
finde es toll dass Anna-Lena bärburg
offensichtlich im Ausland sehr geschätzt
wird dass das finde ich gut dass
da macht sie denke ich eine gute Figur
ich würde es aber trotzdem nicht an Mann
oder Frau festmachen wollen ich finde
immer es muss eine gute Politik sein es
muss ein kluger Mensch nein der da
Deutschland repräsentiert oder der
generell Politik macht er muss fachlich
gut sein er oder sie und deshalb würde
ich immer
plädiere ich immer dafür zuerst den
Menschen zu sehen und dann erst als
zweites das Geschlecht und das versucht
man ja auch zum Beispiel bei den
Bewerbungen fürs Auswärtige Amt mit
psychologischen Eignungstest mit Wissen
hat gerade eben gesagt der
psychologische Eignungstest der Kreis
der ist jetzt gestrichen haben Sie das
Gefühl der findet so eine kleine
Verflachung der Ansprüche jetzt statt im
Amt ja offenbar scheint der massive
verflachen stattfinden
was Frau bärburg macht ich war früher
mal bei den Grünen Mitglied da hieß es
keine Waffen für den Frieden das ist
vollkommen Verdrehung aller grüne
Politik wie ich sie erlebt habe mir
geht's ähnlich wie innen wenn man diesen
Grundfesten der der Grünen Ideen oder
SPD Ideen die mir immer nahe weil wir
mit den treu geblieben ist hat sich das
ganz dramatisch verschoben und jetzt
Panzer für den Frieden zu das
widerspricht allen Grundsätzen die wir
jemals hatten jetzt mit Frieden schaffen
mit Waffen das ist wirklich das verdreht
ins Gegenteil und Frau bärburg sagt doch
wir sind im Krieg mit Russland ich meine
gegen Russland hat glaube es seit 1905
kein Land gewonnen weder Napoleon noch
die Schweden noch irgendwer sie können
dieses russische Volk nicht über Krieg
da nicht gewinnen wir müssen zu einer
Verhandlungslösung führen und was Frau
bärburg da macht auch mit den Sanktionen
gegen Russland die in Wahrheit der
deutschen Ökonomie ungleich mehr Schaden
meine Einschätzung nach als der
russischen Ökonomie also ich halt diese
Außenpolitik für fatal absolut
konfrontativ keinerlei Verhandlung ganz
stur Krieg Krieg Krieg und das aus
grünem Munde also ich schäme mich hier
dass ich mal bei den Grünen Mitglied war
das geht irgendwie überhaupt nicht aber
das liegt eben daran dass zur
Grundausstattung der Grünen eben nicht
nur der Pazifismus gehört sondern auch
die dieser Gedanke des humanitarist
Menschen intervenierens ja also die
ganze Welt ist unsere
verantwortungsfläche wir sind überall
zuständig wir müssen überall hin egal
was passiert überall müssen wir helfen
und retten und das bedeutet natürlich
auch sobald irgendjemand unterdrückt
wird müssen wir ihm helfen oder müssen
ihnen unterstützen das führt dann zu der
Paradoxie wie sich so wunderbar
formuliert haben Frieden schaffen mit
immer mehr Waffen also das ist die
tatsächlich die wie soll man sagen die
Falle in die die Grünen hineingeritten
sind und das erstaunlich ist dass die
Reaktion darauf so milde ist also es
gibt finde ich gerade auch an der grünen
Basis kaum Widerstand gegen diese
Entwicklung obwohl doch eigentlich jeder
diesen Grundgedanken noch zumindest im
Kopf haben müsste
Umweltschutz der Umwelt und Pazifismus
waren die beiden Grundgedanken der
Grünen und auch dass die Familie des
russischen Volkes der russischen
Bevölkerung dass dann bei uns in
russische Dirigent nicht mit dir keine
russische Sängerin nicht mehr singen
kann aus aus grünem Hunde aus im Munde
ein Nationalismus ein diffamieren von
anderen Völkern also ich bin ziemlich
sprachlos wie sich die grüne der
gewandelt haben allen voran Frau bärburg
das wird keinen Frieden schaffen es wird
keine Versöhnung schaffen man muss mit
den anderen Dialog gehen und in dem Maße
wo hier diese Restaurants gegen das
russische Volk auch gegen die Menschen
geschürt werden und sie sagte sie will
das russische Volk auf Jahrzehnte oder
die russische Ökonomie auf Jahrzehnte in
die Knie zwingen diese ganze Rhetorik
das ist ein bisschen das Wording hinein
teilweise schon martialisch kriegerisch
das wird führt zu keinem Frieden diese
Tore sie können am Samstag auf die Demo
gehen von Ali Schweiz
in eine Pause bei Viertel nach Aachen
gleich sind wir hier zurück mit
spannenden Enthüllungen zur
impfstoff-studie bleiben Sie gerne dran
bis gleich wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall